antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et merci de votre
fidélité à une ce soir le financement
des partis politiques
la proposition de françois mitterrand
laisse perplexe certains membres de la
majorité
en deux mots oui à la transparence mais
pas question de tempérer dans quelques
instants
le constat et les perspectives
la petite mélodie enlevés il ya neuf
jours en espagne lance un appel
dramatique à ses parents ses ravisseurs
exigent une rançon de 13 millions de
dollars
l'augmentation du revenu agricole
français pour la deuxième année
consécutive
l'importance des subventions explique en
grande partie cette progression de 2 5%
echard widmark à paris pour la sortie de
son dernier film colère en louisiane le
héros de quarante ans de cinéma
américain décoré de la médaille de
chevalier des arts et lettres journées
supplémentaires de détention pour marcel
carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés l'angoissent l'
angoisse sur la costa del sol en espagne
les ravisseurs de mélodies une petite
fille de 5 ans réclament une rançon de
13 millions de dollars soit 75 millions
de francs
avant ce soir mélodie et la fille de
kymera une chanteuse très connue
son père un milliard un milliardaire
libanais a lancé une véritable supplique
aux ravisseurs ce soir nouveau
rebondissement
les auteurs du rapt viennent d'envoyer
un message de mélodies à ses parents la
cruauté le cynisme des ravisseurs
s'ajoutent à l' angoisse une caissette
trouvait près du casino de marbella
mélodies parle à son père
bah si tu ne paies pas je serai bientôt
mort papa je suis triste je t'aime je
veux te voir la fillette de 5 ans
s'exprime en espagnol
et pourtant d'après son père elle parle
quatre langues la voix est faible
terrorisée avec la cassette une photo de
mélodies qui serait drogué selon raymond
à cacher ans son père regardez la photo
elle ce fut aussi le mess de cheveux des
touches et 16 touchés top à bon port
le milliardaire libanais supplie ses
ravisseurs moi je veux mais changer pour
la halle mais maintenant tout ce qu'il
va se passer c'est ce qu'ils vont bien
trouver une solution duquel sous quelles
solutions
est ce que qui sait quelqu'un quelqu'un
vous demande de donner treize millions
de dollars il n'y a pas de solution
neuf jours que melody a été enlevé à
marbella ici sur le chemin de l'école
les ravisseurs réclament 75 millions de
francs
plusieurs hypothèses sont possibles
vengeance rapt politique
les enquêteurs évoquent même la mafia à
la vie la mélodie c'est le désespoir
il faut en finir une fois pour toutes
avec le problème du financement des
partis politiques
en prononçant cette petite phrase hier
soir à la radio sur rtl le président
s'est placé sur le terrain de la morale
publique tout en mettant en mauvaise
posture ceux qui auraient l'intention de
traîner les pieds a priori le message
est clair et certains n'hésitent pas à
dire que françois mitterrand a mis la
majorité au pied du mur reste à savoir
si techniquement et juridiquement
parlant le vote d'une telle loi peut
intervenir avant les présidentielles de
réponse de daniel brême clairobscur au
palais bourbon
maxime du jour se hâter mais avec
lenteur huit propositions de loi sur le
financement des partis
la majorité avait fait un pas en avant
après les déclarations du président de
la république ce sont plutôt deux pas en
arrière gouvernement ni la majorité
parlementaire n'ont l'intention
d'obtempérer aux demandes voire aux
injonctions du président de la
république il est bien
imprudent de demander au parlement de
faire en six semaines
ce que le président de la république et
les gouvernements socialistes n'ont pas
fait en six ans je suis bien d'accord
pour faire de la morale il ya longtemps
que nous travaillons dans ce sens mais
il faut pas non plus encore une fois des
règles du jeu à clé un problème sérieux
travail série il me paraît que la
réflexion est de circonstance et 6 et me
paraît constituer un élément de deux
possibilités de la candidature de
monsieur françois mitterrand cas ça
ressemble bougrement une promesse
électorale
je suis contre le financement des partis
étant entendu que les partis ont une
existence je dirais constitutionnel
l'article 4 de la constitution par
conséquent moi je pense que c'est
hautement aux adhérents de ces partis à
financer l'activité de leur partie du
consensus bloqué temporisation en bonne
voie ce soir le ps se retrouve donc
isolé le président du groupe a beau
lancer un appel aux députés udf rpr de
bonne volonté
le sursaut consensuel tombe pour le
moment en plein désert des députés udf
ont fait des pourquoi ils surent loi
nous dit jean d'accord prenant pour base
les propositions de lois de l'udf il ya
un député rpr café proprio loi nous
disant prenons là pour base de
discussion
tout reste encore possible comme maître
du jeu le gouvernement françois
mitterrand ne pourra signer une
hypothétique convocation du parlement en
session extraordinaire qu'à une
condition que jacques chirac le lui
demande
et jusqu'à présent il faut bien
reconnaître que la classe politique ne
parlait guère volontiers du financement
des partis politiques la raison est
simple la plupart du temps le
financement s'effectue de manière tout à
fait occulte un flou financier qui
jouent sur des sommes considérables en
france les grandes campagnes
présidentielles ou législatives oscille
entre 80 et 500 millions de francs
olivier lerner
système des trocs cadeaux perpétuelle
renvoi d'ascenseur si l'argent des
partis politiques ne vient pas par ici
il repassera par là les cotisations des
adhérents n'en parlons plus elle
représente à peine 10 % du budget d'un
seul parti plus rentables plus discret
les fonds secrets
chaque année 400 à 500 millions de
francs sont répartis dans les différents
ministères
une somme fixée par le parlement au
cours de la discussion budgétaire plus
sûr et plus sérieux les grands contrats
à l'exportation
le parti au pouvoir perd soit en moyenne
5 % de commission du montant du marché
conclut les intermédiaires sont tous
détenteurs d'un compte bancaire en
suisse plus avant et le plus souvent les
parties sont soutenus par de nombreuses
sociétés privées les grands patrons
donnent volontiers à droite comme à
gauche
même si au ps et au pc on passe plutôt
par les entreprises commerciales chargé
de vendre et revendre différents
services aux municipalités plus discret
et moins visibles les banques elles
jouent un rôle très important
chaque partie à sa banque chaque parti a
également son découvert sur lequel on
ferme les yeux plus opaque et plus
occultes certains états étrangers ne
sont pas absents des grands rendez vous
électoraux urss états unis pays arabes
et africains
chacun de ces pays ac leader préféré
plus subtil et plus juste encore le
service minitel des parties adresses des
permanences chronique de la vie
politique au quotidien mais également
messagerie au contenu plus ou moins rose
à 61 centimes la minute
certains problèmes de gros sous peuvent
être résolus rapidement
tout est bon à prendre père campagne
si chez contrairement à certains pays il
n'est pas possible en france de
contrôler ni même de plafonner les
recettes des partis politiques
certes il ya eu des propositions une
bonne douzaine depuis 1978 mais
curieusement aucune n'a été prise en
considération
laurent boussier et jean-michel mercurol
ont feuilleté les propositions leur
travail de réflexion débouche
pratiquement sur une loi idéal article
1er les hommes politiques présidents
ministres parlementaires devrait rendre
public l'état de leur patrimoine au
début et à la fin de leur mandat
article 2 l'état participerait au
financement des partis politiques
proportionnellement à leur
représentation suffrages et en nombre
d'élus les subventions seraient accordés
à partir d'un seuil plancher de 5 % des
voix article 3 chaque contribuable
verserait 5 francs à titre de
contribution civique pour financer les
partis
article 4 les dons privés des
particuliers associations ou sociétés
seraient plafonnés et déductibles des
impôts
la liste des donateurs seraient rendus
publics interdiction de recevoir toute
forme de subventions venus de l'étranger
article 5 les dépenses de campagne
électorale serait plafonné la
comptabilité des partis rendue publique
est soumise au contrôle des magistrats
de la cour des comptes
interdiction de toute circulation
d'argent en espèces article 6 tout
manquement à ses règles seraient
sanctionnés par retrait des subventions
à mende annulation d'élection ou peine
de prison
les subventions publiques de partis
politiques existent depuis 20 ans en
allemagne 12 en angleterre
l'état participe aux frais de campagne
dans ces deux pays ainsi qu'en italie
en outre le plafonnement des dépenses
électorales est pratiquée aux états unis
à l'occasion des présidentielles
voilà nous avons pratiquement to be à
vous de méditer dans la sphère grégory
villemin les deux dernières journées de
reconstitution commencé aujourd'hui à
vaucelles dans les vosges homme discret
et minutieux le président simon tente de
déterminer l'endroit exact où le petit
grégory a été jeté dans la vologne il ya
un peu plus de trois ans
reconstitution difficile qui débouche
sur un échec tout au moins momentanée
sur place le reportage de roland sicard
pour le juge simon l'expérience des
mannequins devait être décisive elle
pose en fait plus de questions qu'elle
n'apporte de réponses
tout l'enjeu était d'établir si grégory
a pu être assassiné à l'extérieur du
village de docelles lestés dans un
premier temps le mannequin a coulé très
rapidement mais dans une seconde
expérience il a franchi les obstacles
qui le séparait du centre du village là
où le corps de grégory a finalement été
retrouvé dans cette hypothèse la
culpabilité de christine villemin serait
toujours envisageable je pense qu'il ya
dans ce dossier des charges extrêmement
sérieuse
ce n'est pas moi de les apprécier
je ne suis pas un adepte de la chasse
aux sorcières je constate et j'en
tirerai plus tard avec m lagrange avec
le professeur jacques les hôtes et les
conclusions qui s'imposent
si grégory a été assassiné à l'extérieur
du village loin des habitations
le crime aurait pu être commis vers 17
ans au moment où aucun témoin ne peut
confirmer l'entrée du temps de christine
villemin
seulement pour la défense l'expérience
des mannequins est loin d'être
concluante
si le pauvre petit grégory avait été
jeté au fameux endroit prix légers moi
je pense qu'ils se seraient rapidement
enfoncé dans l'eau comme le premier
mannequin mais même s'il avait flotté il
y aurait eu un phénomène de charriage
incontestable et il ne serait pas arrivé
au lieu où on l'a découvert il se trouve
à 400 mètres plus loin
sans porter la moindre et qui mousse
donc ça c'est extrêmement important ce
soir le juge simon en main l'ensemble
des éléments du dossier un dossier
auquel il manque sans doute toujours
pourtant la preuve qui pourrait
permettre d'éclaircir trois ans après
les faits le mystère de la mort du petit
grégory l'actualité en chiffres
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
revenu des agriculteurs est en hausse il
est en hausse de +2 5% 87 après le +0 7%
86 la commission des comptes de
l'agriculture explique cette progression
par la baisse des charges et des frais
financiers et par l'importance des aides
et autres subventions
maryse mano et roger mathurin ont
rencontré un couple d'agriculteurs qui
gère une ferme en loire atlantique
leur témoignage est très révélateur
écouter un conte le chi du du revenu
agricole tombe je rigole tout de suite
je pense aux fonctionnaires qui le
revenu bloqué puis celui celui des
recruteurs qui montre et qui est si
faible alors c'est gênant quoi
c'est un refrain connu très peu
d'agriculteurs se reconnaître dans un
chiffre officiel et pourtant leur venue
de pascal bonfils est tout à fait dans
la moyenne de cette année à une
augmentation de 2%
même si le prix de ces légumes a baissé
sur papier bon c'est sûr avec les
subventions les aides de serre les
abattements de charge pour les
saisonniers
notre revenu sur papier ou de moins ça
c'est ça revenus c'est par un revenu
disponible pour nous vrai revenu foire
hui on nous y distingue la limite même
ubs
la solution de l'énigme la boëtie sur un
revenu brut de 50 mille francs par an
pascal bonfils a reçu 25 millions de
subventions soit la moitié de ce qu'il
gagne
il s'agit des indemnités pour le gel de
l'hiver 85 86 et des prises en charge de
cotisations sociales pour l'emploi de
saisonniers sans cette aide
l'exploitation aurait été déficitaire
pour lui la solution c'est une
reconversion dans la fleur coupée
production mieux payé pour d'autres
c'est le salaire de l'épousé quand elles
travaillent à l'extérieur où la double
activité
ce n'est pas le cas ici rappelons que
quatre agriculteurs sur dix ont
aujourd'hui en revenus extra et
agricoles à la bourse de paris nouvel
accès de mauvaise humeur aujourd'hui -
1,96 en clôture le dollar est également
à la baisse à 5 francs 74 apparemment
les dernières petites phrases du
président reagan ont jeté un froid sur
les marchés boursiers et monétaires
d'une manière impromptue le président
avait affirmé hier soir que la réduction
du déficit budgétaire américain serait
moins importante que prévue aujourd'hui
à paris monsieur béryl sprinkle qui est
le chef des conseillers économiques de
la maison blanche a confirmé que le
président reagan n'avait pas l'intention
d'augmenter les impôts voilà qui va
contribuer à faire renaître une certaine
tension
écoutons le le président reagan a été
très clair lors de son discours hier il
est fermement opposée à des
augmentations d'impôts qu'elle soit
importante ou non cela était sa position
depuis le début c'est toujours la même
eau
aujourd'hui et j'espère qu'il n'en
changera pas et sur ce point je le
soutiens entièrement
d'un côté le dollar toujours dans la
tourmente de l'autre le yen en pleine
santé moralité les japonais multiplient
les investissements à l'étranger
notamment en france
sensible au prestige et aux charmes de
paris les japonais s'installe en plein
coeur de la capitale
coût de l'opération tenez vous bien 2,5
milliards de francs
c'est la plus grosse opération
immobilière depuis la construction de la
tour montparnasse
françoise joly en plein centre de paris
à deux pas de la tour montparnasse
les japonais vont déposer deux milliards
et demi de francs sur une dalle de béton
cette plateforme doit recouvrir la
future gare du tgv atlantique
elle sera surtout le socle nécessaire à
la construction d'un immense complexe
regroupant plus de soixante douze mille
mètres carrés de bureaux de commerces
mais aussi des jardins et même des
courts de tennis
la com à une société japonaise finance
cette opération immobilière
l'occasion pour les japonais de
diversifier leurs investissements à
l'étranger
je crois qu'ils s'intéressent maintenant
la france particulièrement paris parce
que je crois qu'ils ont fait confiant
conscience que paris était une capitale
internationale et je crois que cet
investissement se place dans le cadre de
92 du marché commun je crois que c'est
un point important pour eux d'avoir
reconnu que par est devenue une capitale
internationale
le chantier atlantique montparnasse va
durer quatre ans c'est la première fois
que les japonais finance un tel projet
immobilier en france
les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité en images ensuite direction
new york pour voir comment les
américains accueillent le livre de
michael gorbatchev
les stations des victimes de bhopal
union carbide faire à 500 millions de
dollars un compromis avec le
gouvernement indien qui a réclamé 3
milliards ça 138 plaintes ont été
déposées 2006 160 personnes avaient été
tuées par la fuite de gaz toxique en
décembre 95 je veux niveau riaom clé de
la crise italienne quatre jours après la
démission de son gouvernement c'est
encore lui qui doit former une nouvelle
coalition
un objectif pour le démocrate chrétien
fait revenir les libéraux un obstacle le
déficit budgétaire 79 milliards de
dollars pour 81 sésame berger à vous il
était officier ss pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale en était vendredi en
argentine il serait responsable du
meurtre de centaines de juifs en pologne
son extradition vers la rfa pourrait
avoir lieu le mois prochain rhône
paralysés par des milliers de retraités
le troisième âge protesté aujourd'hui
contre l'austérité du gouvernement une
revendication l'indexation des retraites
sur la grille des salaires pérestroïka
le livre de mikhaïl gorbatchev sort
demain aux états unis paul nahon notre
correspondant à new york a eu l'idée de
confier ce livre de l'année à monsieur
brodinski l'ancien conseiller du
président carter ce dernier a
semble-t-il apprécié avant de l'écouter
je crois qu'il est utile de vous
rappeler comment est né ce livre au
départ il ya l'idée un peu folle qui est
né dans la tête d'un éditeur écoutez
michael et cornélia b6 dirige une
collection dans l'une des plus grandes
et prestigieuses maisons d'édition new
york
harper et n'auront il y a deux ans ils
ont eu l'idée folle demandé à michael
gorbatchev qui accède au pouvoir
d'écrire un livre
pas de réponse pendant un an puis alors
qu'il ne s'y attendent plus le leader
soviétique acceptent et leur demande de
venir en russie
pour lire le livre qu'il a paraît-il
écrit en crimée pendant ces longues
vacances du mois d'août dernier
ce manuscrit en deux exemplaires qu'on
nous a été apporté à la même classe
nous étions à ce moment là alors on se
met à lire quand tout d'un coup vous
êtes mis à lire le livre de gorbatchev s
et vous l'aviez trouvez vous en tant
qu'éditeur franchement vous l'avais
trouvé très bon tout de suite très bon
un vrai livre un vrai livre
vous savez nous sommes sortis de la
russie avec ce manuscrit
on l'a mis en oeuvre en septembre on l'a
mis en fabrication et je crois que
c'était des semaines après on a appris
qu'il y aura un sommet coincidence ou
pas à quelques jours du sommet de
washington la publication du livre de
mikhaïl gorbatchev apparaît comme une
bonne opération pour le kremlin
mais nous l'avons donné à lire un des
plus célèbres spécialistes américains
speak newbury gince qui l'ancien
secrétaire d'état
le livre est plus libérale plus ouverts
je dirais plus pointus en fait ce n'est
pas la langue de bois prudente et
laborieuse de ses discours officiels
alors pour la petite histoire les
éditeurs de ce livre ont demandé à
michael gorbatchev de leur donner une
photo de son choix pour mettre à
l'arrière de ce livre michael gorbatchev
envoyer une photo et vous remarquerez
que sur cette photo il porte au front la
tâche de vin qu'il a toujours eue alors
qu'elle est comme et sur les photos
officielles
décidément monsieur gorbatchev fait un
tabac aux états unis son épouse raïssa a
déclaré devant la presse que bon nombre
d'américains étaient prêts à les
accueillir au cours du prochain sommet
bref les américains sont plus
hospitalier que jamais patricia cost
l'événement n'est pas de première
importance
mais il est de bonne augure pour les
relations entre les deux grands comme le
souligne le commentateur américain qui a
interviewé une reiss à gorbatchev plein
de bonne volonté lors de l'inauguration
d'une exposition de peinture américaine
du 19e siècle
la première dame du rsf confirme
précision de taille que le sommet aurait
bien lieu malgré les difficultés de
dernière minute en ce moment à genève et
communication oblige reiss à corbas de
chef raconte qu'elle reçoit chaque jour
un grand nombre de lettres des états
unis de la part d'hommes de femmes de
tout âge la vie temps à venir visiter
qui sa ferme si sa maison qui sa
province
et bouquet final certains america lui
envoie même la clé de leur logis pour
lui montrer à quel point ils font
confiance aux soviétiques à poitiers
ouverture demain du deuxième grand
procès consacré au dopage beaucoup moins
de monde dans le box des accusés
la lan il y à un mois mais plus de
personnalité directement mouillé entre
guillemets dans des affaires qui
touchent de très près le cyclisme et
l'haltérophilie
comme toujours en paille en pareil cas
il sera très difficile de faire éclater
la vérité
en quête de thierry blancot problème de
la sphère de poitiers la mort d'un
coureur cycliste amateur jean philippe
foucher 31 ans le vélo c'était son gagne
pain
pas question d'arrêter malgré les
problèmes cardiaques dont il souffrait
problèmes pour lesquels en 82 le chu est
un cardiologue de poitiers lui
interdisent de reprendre la compétition
question qui lui a délivré une nouvelle
licence sachant que fouchier comme bon
nombre de coureurs amateurs de sa région
on est en plus des produits dopants
tonné dont entre autres quand vous
prenez quelque chose vous avez envie de
faire du vélo vous allez envie de
bagarre est survenue et que je vous dis
quand vous avez pris la continence de
vous piquer de prendre des comprimés bon
bah c'est difficile de s'en passer pour
faire du vélo ou même dans la vie
courante
oui moi quand j'ai arrêté le vélo
j'avoue ça a été très dur pour moi
passer une affaire aux ramifications
multiples au total 23 ans inculpé parmi
eux le patron d'une salle de musculation
de poitiers lequel se défend d'avoir
jamais utilisé ce produit comme un
dopant j'ai utilisé ce produit mais par
la voie légale à un moment de ma vie où
j'étais un peu fatigué et mon médecin
m'a prescrit ce médicament également
dans le box des accusés des médecins et
des pharmaciens en toile de fond
certificats de complaisance et peut-être
trafic de produits dopants
le monde du cyclisme une nouvelle fois
sur la sellette problèmes cardiaques ou
dopage il y à cette fois une victime de
31 ans le football dans ma mère vous
avez sous les yeux la composition de
l'équipe de france avant le match
international qui compte pour du beurre
france rda mais enfin il faut être sur
le terrain bon il ya des surprises un
wii 2 surprise avec la titularisation
des deux nouveaux appelés le parisien
germain du matra racing et le médecin
kastendeuch ils seront les 96e et 97e
joueur appelé en équipe de france grand
retour également de bruno bellone vous
le constater sur notre petit panneau
après un an de purgatoire
henri michel a choisi pour jouer à ses
côtés cantona touré fargeau eux seront
sur le banc des remplaçants
l'entraîneur henri michel cherche un
équilibre psychologique et surtout
physique il faudra il a donné sa
composition d'équipé dernier moment pour
que ses joueurs restent le plus
concentré possible
ils en auront bien besoin face à l'eire
dr demain soir à 20 heures au parc des
princes 20h par les princes à part c'est
une confirmation jules bocandé ou qui
que paris saint germain
oui il a bien il est prêté pour la fin
de la saison à nice il s'en ira dès
demain matin sur la côte d'azur et il
pourrait être qualifié dès samedi pour
jouer contre lille avec son nouveau club
allez une colle gens vous êtes un grand
spécialiste sportif quel est le meilleur
goal du monde le meilleur gardien de but
je dirais le soviétique d'assayas même
s'il a pris six bus récemment non mais
c'est lui mais moi j'en connais un autre
c'est le plus mauvais effet et regardez
regardez les images alors suivait les
pas bons et on va on va essayer de vous
faire la petite démonstration allait
envoyer nous les images et c'est un
monsieur qui va l'arrêter le ballon jean
oui c'est le gardien de l'équipe
d'andorre qui jouent contre l'espagne il
va dégager
eh ben on regarde oui mais dans son cas
le plus grave c'est qu'il est et non à
l'armée non non non il n'y a pas but dit
il a vu et on recommence portable avait
là la preuve est là mais il est bien il
a toujours pas compris
jamais je ne sais pas si ça sera le plus
le plus bête de l'histoire mais c'est
sans doute le plus sans doute le budget
de l'aide à tous ne peut pas dire
qu'elle ait pas de faux mouvement pour
la météo laurent qu'est ce que vous nous
vous prévoyez pour demain bien
l'anticyclone nuit bétonne chinois
craint que l'équipe adverse
il ya en fait nous allons profiter quand
même deux de ces belles journées
d'automne que le ciel nous donne c'est
vrai que l'anticyclone bétonne il
cartonne en ce moment et la nature
rayonne alors que va-t-il se passer
demain et bien si vous avez un baromètre
vous avez plus tapoter et vous êtes
aperçu d'une chose c'est que sur ce
baromètre les pressions sont encore à la
hausse nous allons 1031 1032 millibars
hectopascals cela signifie que nous
sommes toujours d'un bureau de pression
cela veut dire aussi que nous aurons
demain des brumes et des brouillards au
lever du jour
nous allons voir tout de suite sur la
couleur du temps je vais voir ces bruits
mais ces brouillards qui seront surtout
présents sur les charrons que le poitou
la vendée mais également le sud ouest
les pays-de-loire bref dans toutes ces
régions
c'est là où ils seront le plus dense la
tempe et puis quand même nom un petit
mot pour vous dire que un soleil
rayonnant sur littoral méditerranéen
il fallait le souligner pour les
températures pendant que vous observez
les températures qui sont proches de
chez vous vous rendez vous indiquer
qu'il y aura des
les demain matin sur la bourgogne le
centre le limousin le massif central il
fera deux petits degrés à paris demain
matin au lever du jour et un petit
degrés à lyon et nous aurons entre 8 et
10 degrés dans cette région ici à
charmes charme alors il ya plusieurs
gars à vous dans les vosges en haute
marne en meurthe et moselle et même dans
le rhône voyez que la france ne manque
pas de charme et demain donc mardi
mercredi 18 novembre le lever du soleil
sera à 8h05 le même soleil repliera six
rayons à 17h06 et bonne fête les zones
prochain rendez vous d'information 23h30
exactement avec aubry et de l'air demain
à partir de 6h45 n'oubliez pas télé
matin à 7h45 c'est françois périgot le
président du cnpf qui sera l'invité des
4 vérités
merci de votre fidélité et à demain 20h
excellente soirée sera belle
vous